le césar est attribué à guillaume canet
gaspard ulliel fiers d'y mettre un peu
la nouvelle génération sont un peu ce
que vous étiez à l'époque
je vois pas trop la différence entre eux
et moi quoi donc quand même vous faites
partie des acteurs orange et saluons pu
tout je comprends pas trop comment vous
voyez vous vous trompez sous prétexte
qu'on est en couple ça veut dire qu'on
mette plus je baise moi ma part c'est
que ce soir je disais comme une bonne
grosse [ __ ]
donc je sais une phrase de dialogue pour
une scène que j'ai donc fait un drôle de
v ner tu vois plus
quand je vais dire à ma mère que je vous
ai rencontrés elle va être comme une
dingue ah ouais vous êtes une longue et
belle fin de carrière ça laissait ainsi
qu'au nord
je mérite tellement car j'avais
l'impression de voir il s'intitule a
connu tout ce moment pas plus que ça on
va sûrement tiger woods à paroles
paroles là qu'est ce qui t'arrive ça
demande un peu ce que je fais là en fait
nous sommes là pour en parler ça fait
envie mais ça peut effrayer ou
appartement
[Musique]
pourquoi tu as fait
l'amour
je crois que regarder
[Musique]